o cabelo ruim cara de empregada negra
maluca cara de bandido nariz de batata
negra feia a coisa de preto
essas são algumas palavras e expressões
diretamente ligadas às pessoas negras no
brasil ea pergunta que motivou o início
do meu trabalho foi será que tem alguma
forma da gente conseguir mudar isso
se você assim como eu nasceu antes dos
anos 2000 tem alguém aí que nasceu antes
muito provavelmente você teve alguma
dessas pessoas aqui como referência para
as meninas dos anos 90 80
essa era a imagem do sonho do belo do
espelho a ser seguido para os meninos
essa era a imagem da mulher que merecia
os olhares a mulher ideal mas aí eu te
pergunto e quando você é totalmente o
oposto dessa imagem
e quando as mesmas mídias que apresentam
essa imagem como ideal só apresentam
pessoas parecidas com você
na imagem na no papel da pessoa da
empregada de pele escura que tá ali
sempre para servir os patrões não tem
família não tem história
dócil mas serve só como pano de fundo ou
da escrava escravo que nunca se
articulou para alcançar a liberdade
estavam todos conformados tem também a
barraqueira o bandido
o menino preto abandonado e não dá pra
esquecer da figura quase que mística que
só aparecia nos carnavais
isso tudo debaixo do mito da democracia
racial que dizia que por conta da
miscigenação o racismo não era isso tudo
por aqui
isso foi crescer sendo uma criança negra
a eterna tentativa de se adequar
eu lembro que na minha infância eu criei
o hábito de colocar um pregador no nariz
durante algumas horas por dia
isso quando a minha mãe não tava vendo
aí você pode me perguntar o porquê
já naquela época eu entendi que o nariz
como o meu não era considerado bonito
uma estética como a minha não era muito
bem vista
afinal o que eu escutava era o nariz
bonito é nariz fino cabelo bom é cabelo
liso quem já ouviu falar
eu lembro também que por muito tempo meu
sonho foi ser babá e minha mãe
perguntava de onde você tirou isso
e aqui eu não estou de forma alguma
desvalorizando a profissão não existe
problema nenhum em ser babá ou empregada
doméstica
o problema é quando um grupo de pessoas
entende que milagrosamente aquelas
profissões são destinadas a elas
não existe outra possibilidade outra
alternativa
isso é o que me faz pensar que as mídias
não só reforçaram essa ideia elas
continuam reforçando na piscina na
pesquisa raça e gênero nas telenovelas
eles analisaram mais de 100 obras
vinculadas entre 1995 e 2014
e concluiu se que nessas obras
noventa por cento dos personagens
centrais eram pessoas brancas e essa
informação não estava pra muito mais do
que falta representatividade porque não
necessariamente não existiam pessoas
negras ali o problema era aí é como
essas pessoas são representadas
foram anos e anos reforçando
estereótipos anos mostrando essas
pessoas nas mesmas posições
eu acredito que pra isso mudar ou nós
iniciarmos o início dessa mudança
nós precisaríamos de um esforço muito
insistente de representação dessas
pessoas em outros lugares mas será que
dava para esperar as grandes mídias
acordarem e decidirem mudar
não não dava para esperar a mão que
escreve os roteiros continua sendo a
mesma
agora essa é a imagem do vídeo meu
intitulado tur pelo meu rosto
nele eu trago uma nova narrativa sobre a
estética negra
eu falo das minhas experiências falou
dos meus traços e esse vídeo hoje conta
com
cerca de 9 milhões de visualizações e
comentários como esses que eu falei pra
vocês aqui
obrigada por esse vídeo desde o ano
passado estou buscando uma alta
aceitação
estou redescobrindo o meu corpo negro as
gengivas escuras foram uma questão para
mim na infância eu buscava não sorrir
muito nas fotos para os para não mostrá
las sempre amei meus lábios
em compensação o nariz sempre foi um
caso de ódio
hoje me olho no espelho e me acho tão
bonita com o rosto delicado com uma cor
linda
outro comentário minha filha tem um ano
e já estou colocando esse vídeo na
playlist para ela aprender mais ainda
com mulheres como você só mais um eu te
acho tão linda o que faz eu me perguntar
por que eu não posso me achar bonita
também
e não para por aí
eu assim como muitos outros criadores de
conteúdo que nunca fomos representados
para além dos estereótipos
estamos hoje usando uma nova mídia para
construir uma nova narrativa novas
tentativas essas que impactam
positivamente pessoas e causam
transformação social no meu canal eu
falo sobre o racismo e seus impactos
falo bastante mas eu também falo sobre
intercâmbio morar sozinha
relacionamentos maquiagem e sabe por quê
porque nós existimos para além do
racismo e dos estereótipos que nos foram
impostos
eu gosto sempre de me afastar da ideia
que nós estamos construindo uma contra
narrativa
por quê
isso faz parecer que a gente tá sempre
partindo do outro quase que uma posição
e não a gente está construindo uma nova
narrativa
há um tempo atrás eu cheguei à conclusão
que eu não tinha mais tempo para
desconstruir o meu objetivo se tornou
construir construir pessoas que entendam
o seu lugar no espaço entendam seu lugar
nessa sociedade que sabem os seus
direitos que vão descobrir que a
história delas não se resume à
escravidão e serventia que nós fomos
reis rainhas e inventores matemáticos
que nós precisamos cuidar da nossa saúde
física e mental lutar contra esse
genocídio
a minha ideia é construir e agora eu
tenho uma pergunta pra você que está
assistindo que nova narrativa você quer
colocar no mundo seja dentro ou fora da
internet que nova história você quer
trazer luz
eu vim aqui não só do meu exemplo e de
incentivar
eu vim mostrar que é possível
obrigada
[Aplausos]